la muse folie de pommes de terre et de
vitres fumées du lac
bon appétit
marc veyrat a commencé apprenti à 13 ans
et demi rebutés par les écoles
hôtelières le petit de manigod à percer
en haute savoie qui tient aujourd'hui
l'une des meilleurs temps à autre pour
les ombles chevaliers petit pavé de
carrière de femme de théâtre monfort
bassam abou dan kersch voulez des
preuves et ce que l'on sait avec en
poche environ en croit entre trois et
quatre minutes sait faire c'est le nom
centre m
vous allez donner des boudins sur un
plateau messieurs bref on faisait pas
chaud sourit l'ancien nas et noir son
petit pavé de caviar de pommes de terre
et de truite fumée du lac d'annecy lui a
valu deux étoiles michelin aujourd'hui
gaultmillau berné la clé d'or qui
distingue le talent d'un jeune chef
prometteur
à 35 ans ce n'est qu'un début a je crois
que la qualité première
cela reste vrai cette phrase une phoque
une
une réponse de mon épouse qui m'a
toujours des fois même le client passe
avant la famille
je pense qu'il faut être assidu il faut
être motivé pour son travail si vous
êtes motivé e fois en france ma main je
suis là que trois heures et demie je
suis très heureux pour 8,50
bon